Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, yesterday in
my Arrow review I asked you all to submit
questions so I picked 10 of them to answer
with one bonus question.
We also got official news about Grant Gustin’s
Flash tv show.
So i’ll talk about that first before we
do questions.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do Arrow videos every week.
Because the new Flash show is basically a
spinoff I’m going to be doing weekly videos
for that too.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I’ll probably combine Q&As for both of those
since they exist in a shared Universe.
Like they’re going to cross over.
So big news today, The CW officially picked
up The Flash.
Which means it will start airing episodes
in the Fall.
In addition, the first trailer is supposed
to air during the Arrow Finale.
That’s what my bonus video will be next
Wednesday.
So I’ll do that separately from my review
of the Arrow Finale.
They’re also probably going to use that
Trailer to announce which day the show will
air.
I would guess that it’s either going to
air back to back with Arrow Season 3 on the
same night.
Like right after Arrow to benefit from that
audience.
Once Arrow goes off the Air I’ll just alternate
between Arrow and Flash bonus videos every
week.
I’m also expecting them to air the pilot
episode at Comic Con, if that happens I’ll
be sure to post a non-spoilery review.
On to Questions, careful for spoilers from
the episode if you haven’t seen it yet.
Here we go.
Question 1 - Delaneyel asks do you think they
will ever start calling Oliver "Green Arrow"
instead of just "Arrow"?﻿
No I don’t think the show is going to use
the Green part.
There’s definitely been an evolution of
his identity since season 1.
He started out as the vigilante and then became
the Arrow.
Remember when Quentin was talking to his Sergeant
in the episode.
The Sergeant called Oliver the Vigilante and
Quentin corrected him by saying, The Arrow.
I think more people will just start thing
of him less as a vigilante and more as a force
for good.
But even Batman was never percieved as a 100
percent good guy.
The beauty of being the Arrow is that Oliver
can walk the line of justice more than the
police.
So he’ll never be like Superman who Batman
calls “The Boy Scout”.
Question 2 - Sapphire Blue (no avatar) asks
What do you think about photo from next episode
where Slade is taking Felicity hostage?﻿
It’s a nice teaser for him killing the one
Oliver loves most, but if you remember the
love algebra I did in my review.
He loves all the women equally.
So by default there would be no one woman
he would love the most.
So I think something else is going on in that
scene.
I mean, Slade is probably going to kill a
bunch of people anyway, so Felicity probably
just gets snagged in the crossfire.
There were some behind the scenes images they
shot at a water treatment facility with a
bunch of pipes.
So I’m guessing that’s where that scene
takes place.
But I have no idea what the location is doubling
for.
Some sort of power plant maybe.
Felicity’s already confirmed for Season
3, so we know she’ll get out of that situation
some how.
The list of people that actually have real
chance of dying is pretty small.
Question 3 - David Alvarado asks Do you think
that similar to Quentin being promoted to
Commissioner, that Laurel could be DA next
season since Kate Spencer was killed?﻿
I don’t think Quentin will be commissioner,
but I do think that Laurel could be District
Attorney.
There’s a lot of Black Canary, Sara dying
talk going on, but even if Laurel does become
Black Canary in season 3.
It’s going to take all season for her to
get there.
She’s not just going to show up in episode
1 in black leather.
I think we’ll just see her working in a
position of power where she can help prosecute
the criminals Team Arrow takes down.
Plus with Quentin back to detective status
he has a lot more freedom to help them out
too.
Team Arrow will just become more effective.
Question 4 - Kim asks Do you think there is
a possibility that Merlyn helps out team Arrow?
He’s actually standing next to them in the
trailer.
So definitely.
Oliver still has a lot of unfinished business
with him and Thea still doesn’t like him.
So I don’t think Merlyn will be a good guy
from now on.
He’ll just have a temporary truce while
they deal with the shit storm.
There’s a lot of rumors that he could also
be the big villain in Season 3.
Or be the big villain again.
Sins of the father was something Isabel talked
about when she revealed her plan to Oliver.
So I like the idea of Thea’s father, Merlyn
and Felicity’s Father, who we haven’t
met.
Turning out to be the villains of Season 3.
The thing about all the different plot threads
going each season is that they all have to
connect by the finale.
For instance, the one common denominator this
season is Oliver and Slade’s relationship.
So in Season 3 I really like the idea of Felicity’s
relationship with her Father or Thea’s being
the common denominator.
And don’t forget.
Oliver has a son, so sins of the father has
a whole new meaning now.
That relationship will be a big plot point
in season 3 too.
Fathers and Sons, Fathers and daughters.
It would work out a lot better if Oliver had
a daughter.
Which is funny, because in real life Stephen
Amell has a daughter.
Question 5 - Marvel DC asks How do you think
roy will react after he wakes up?
He’ll probably be horrified at what he’s
done to everyone and to Thea.
I think he’ll spend season 3 trying to repair
that relationship and atone for his crimes
against the city.
Those demons will be what motivates him to
be a hero.
And yes, I do think he won’t have super
strength or healing anymore.
He’ll be back to normal.
Oliver is the benchmark for hero on the show.
He’s a totally normal person with no super
powers and he still does the work of a hero
just like the other Justice League members.
Same deal with Batman, it’s doing what they
do without superpowers that makes them heroes.
So Roy is just going to ride that train going
forward.
Question 6 - Jose asks Do you think Oliver
should take the mirikuro?
No, I actually just explained it in that last
question.
But let’s talk about the consequences if
he did take it.
No one so far has been immune to the mental
side effects.
So if Oliver took it he’d succumb to the
madness too.
He’d probably hallucinate his father.
He actually spent most of season 1 on the
island hallucinating him.
He’d flip out and turn into the Frank Castle
Punisher and just start murdering supervillains
and Amanda Waller would have to nuke Starling
City all over again.
Slade and Oliver are essentially the same
person.
Slade went to the dark side and Oliver became
Luke Skywalker.
I’m still waiting to see if he’s able
to redeem Darth Slade.
Question 7 - The Sedinam (no avatar) asks
They keep destroying the city each season,
did they even fully rebuild it after the undertaking?
Good point, no they never fully rebuilt the
Glades.
That was where the blast went off.
It got worse and that’s what Brother Blood
built his campaign for mayor on.
He was like this is a problem no one cares
about but me, I’ll fix this city.
So the city itself is still broken.
Now they’re breaking it again, even if they
don’t nuke it.
Slade’s army has trashed it.
So I expect Queen Industries to be a big part
of healing it between the finale and the season
3 finale.
I don’t think it will be fixed when season
3 starts.
I think Oliver will become a much more active
participant in making the city better with
his company.
The big question is how he’s going to get
his company back.
I’m really interested to see how they deal
with that plot point.
Question 8 - Sam Hockney asks Do you think
Thea will learn Oliver's identity?
Yes I hope so.
If she knows all about Merlyn she’s halfway
there already.
She started to question the connection between
Slade and Oliver so I’m hoping he does the
same thing he did with Roy.
Where he ripped his mask off and made this
really passionate speech.
Merlyn is going to stay with Thea, and if
Merlyn is marching with them in the trailer
it means they all have to meetup at some point.
I’m really looking forward to that reunion.
Oliver still doesn’t know Merlyn is alive.
Question 9 - MTA Critic asks What other kinds
of trick arrows do you think Oliver would
use in the future?﻿
I think they’ll actually attach the mirakuru
cure to oliver and merlyn’s arrows.
I guess you could call mirakuru cure tipped
arrows trick arrows.
I think you’re asking about regular trick
arrows though.
Realistically he could use EMP arrows like
Hawkeye did in Avengers.
Stephen Amell said he really wants more trick
arrows too, so don’t be surprised if there
are a few new ones next season.
Question 10 - Geesma asks Do you think they’ll
change Oliver’s Costume or his look in season
3?
Not really, not in a significant way.
Usually the lead actor is the one that changes
the least.
They’re like the throughline for the whole
series so for the most part, they need to
change the least.
At least from a physical standpoint.
And if Oliver changes his leather pants, Felicity
won’t be able to make jokes about them anymore.
Bonus Question - KJ Bucane asks What DC Superhero
do you want to see get a tv show next?
Gosh, they have so many in development.
In terms of actual shows.
I think Suicide Squad would be next.
But if I had to pick a single superhero it
would have to be either Deathstroke, Vandal
Savage or Nyssa Al Ghul.
It would have to be a villain.
We’ve seen so many new hero shows, now it’s
time to see a villain get their own show.
If it were Vandal Savage it could be like
an Injustice Society Show and if it were Nyssa
Al Ghul it could be like a League of Assassin’s
Show.
It’s much more likely to get a show based
on a character that’s already been established
on Arrow or another show.
But thanks so much for submitting questions,
these are always a ton of fun to do.
And remember, be on the lookout for a special
cameo in the finale and a trailer for The
Flash.
If we do get a trailer.
I’ll make it my bonus video.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Right now click here for my review of the
episode and click here to learn all about
my new bonus channel.
That’s right bonus gaming channel.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!